on last night's show we had a treat we
had the nine cast members from one of my
all-time favorite shows Game of Thrones
loved that show
they were great it was a thrill for me
personally unfortunately we ran really
short on time I got to ask everyone in
the cast a question but we ended up
having to break from the show before I
got to speak with liam Cunningham who
plays Davos and I felt really bad about
that so I thought why not bring liam
Cunningham back tonight ladies and
gentlemen I called him because I felt so
bad and I want to apologize he agreed to
return late Simon here he is liam
Cunningham
thank you thank you thank you so much
for coming back I wanted to ask you the
question I didn't get to ask you
yesterday with Melisandre arriving at
Winterfell do you think that Davos will
now seek to avenge Stannis go yourself
I thought that went well yeah seems
touchy hey thanks for watching be sure
to click subscribe to see even more
great Conan clips you may now return to
your pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography